And,
uh,
today we have a Aardman animations,
amazing creative team.
We have nick park who's a director of a,
the new film early man and Merlin crossing handle.
[inaudible] so thanks so much for coming here guys.
This is phenomenal.
You guys brought some of your characters puppets,
um,
which is so cool,
especially seeing the one that's cut in half so we can see all the innards of it
and everything.
Um,
so,
uh,
I want to start with you,
nick.
Um,
and creator of Wallace and gromit,
which is amazing.
We Love Wallace and gromit everyone knows what was and I'm so I kind of want to
go back to,
um,
kind of the start of this story of where this came from,
how it came to
yeah.
Early on.
Yeah,
yeah,
sure.
Well,
Gosh,
a lot of these things start with just do those other page.
Um,
and uh,
I remember help me five or six,
seven years ago,
um,
you know,
doing the typical kind of caveman with a club,
hitting a rock and then suddenly started thinking about the whole potential for
caveman and the women in vet inventing sport.
And particular because of the tribal nature of soccer in the UK,
it just seemed to have a lot of legs,
you know,
that it's a developed to run literally with the idea.
And what,
what if you had a bunch of lunkhead idiotic but lovable caveman who had to learn
the discipline of a sport.
We're no longer able to use their weapons and fists,
um,
and had to fight for what they need need by playing your game.
And that was how it kind of,
how the whole idea is off.
It's,
it's a really,
really fun film.
It's really funny and I love it.
You guys are still keeping stop motion alive and still doing them.
And I love just the process of how it all comes together.
It's,
it's amazingly painstaking to do and for Merlin.
And will you guys,
um,
how can I talk about your guys' career,
the studio when you guys came to the studio and then what brought you into this
part?
I think,
Oh,
I've worked at for about 22 years.
I've stopped it as an animator and then slipped into directing and have worked
with alongside nick for most of that.
And uh,
it's really wonderful to be able to help me bring his vision to,
to an audience up on the screen.
Say we actually worked with Merlin and uh,
nick and ironman to create a Google doodle back in 2009.
So,
um,
which is really cool stuff.
You guys should check it out.
google.com/doodles I don't need to check all the archive.
Nice little plug there.
Um,
yeah.
And um,
similarly to Merlin,
I've worked with nick.
I have a few feature films and I actually wrote him a letter at about the age of
14 to say,
how do I become an animator?
He wrote back and gave me some advice and then a very kindly Aardman supporting
me through college can be lots of tips and develop from that.
And what drew you guys to stop motion specifically?
For me,
it's just the tactile nature of it and the fact that you can create everything.
Um,
it's a very instant thing when you start the animators on this film.
Create very little actual footage in a week.
But when you first start doing an animation,
it's quite quick.
You can take a ball of clay and make it move and come to life and see the
results straight away.
Yeah.
For me,
I was already studying animation,
learning and TD.
I haven't,
yeah,
I can draw,
but it's,
I have to work at it.
And sculpting is just a much more natural medium for me,
so I can express myself,
uh,
much more fluently in sculpting.
Yeah.
And how about you?
I read that you,
so you were students and that's when urban kinds of,
hey,
come on and we'll fund your project.
And then ended up actually being Wallace and gromit.
Is that right?
That's right.
Wallace and gromit was a,
a film school.
I was at film school and it was my graduation film and I was taking years over
it and I ran out of time and money.
It feels skill.
And I got to know Peter Lloyd and David Sproxton who have had already started
apartment a few years before that.
And they were the only people I knew of who did stop.
You know,
clay animation.
So,
uh,
a neighbor,
they were expanding and looking for animators.
And I think I was the only one they knew really at the time.
So they kept calling me up and I wonder,
I had this vision,
I had to finish my film.
I'm an altar,
you know,
director.
Uh,
uh,
and eventually they said,
why don't we help you finish the film?
Um,
and if you come to work for us part time in,
that was in 1985 so I did.
And they did.
They did help me.
They gave me a corner of the studio and it took me another four years to finish
the film.
Yeah.
Well guess so how long does early Matt,
how long early mantic you said about six years from idea?
Yeah.
From idea.
The idea when writing stage is probably the longest stretch really.
The last 18 months was the actual shooting.
The actual animation was 18 months to two years.
But before that,
you know,
the storyboarding,
the set design,
character,
design building,
um,
and the writing before that is a couple of years at least.
Right,
right.
And can you guys talk about a little bit about your like inspirations for,
you know,
with stop motion,
you have Willis O'brien who did like King Kong and,
and money Joe Young,
and then you have ray Harryhausen obviously is most well known for Jason The
argonauts.
And so when you,
um,
did you ever get to meet Harry Housing and work with them at all?
Yeah,
I wouldn't to Ray Harryhausen nice seven,
which was an extraordinary opportunity and experience for me.
He was automation direct turn.
I animated full him and um,
we did it all.
The project we working on,
we,
we did in the way he worked.
Um,
when he first pioneered a lot of the techniques.
It was a real eyeopener for me.
And I,
uh,
I
just in the,
it was on a five week project and just that short amount of time working with a
master like that,
but my,
you know,
I was like a spot and the sheep,
they're just constantly,
I'm not pestering him,
but just trying to absorb some of,
some of that knowledge that,
that he had
created and pioneered pretty much everything that we do.
We don't really do anything different to what rated,
but just,
um,
not so much for visual effects.
More for entertainment.
Yeah.
And did you meet
yeah,
a few times.
Yeah.
Did you will,
he came around,
didn't of the wearer,
but he came for a tour of the studio and he chatted to run a special day.
And the film is very much,
uh,
the opening sequence of this movie.
It's very much a tribute to Ray Harryhausen.
Yeah,
there's two dinosaurs we named one of them ray and one of them Harry,
as well as the state to the crazy cousin re um,
uh,
I guess the,
the,
the big change was going from film to digital stills.
So we shoot everything on high end digital stills,
cameras,
just individual frames,
which uh,
uh,
instantly quicker.
Um,
so everything we shoot on the studio floor goes up to edit and we can review it
there and then,
um,
and next constantly working on the animatic and that the edit.
So,
um,
it's much more immediate now.
We used to have to send the film off to London.
We were in Bristol,
there's not,
there wasn't a lab in Bristol,
so you'd have to send it overnight.
And it wasn't till the next day that you'd all gather around in the theater to
see your dailies and so probably saved six months off the shoot.
Right,
right there.
Right.
And then if something was wrong back in the day,
like where you looked at your dailies where like,
oh,
this is not working,
would you just have to go back and reshoot that or would you just search for
them?
Frames?
Yeah,
yeah.
Digital,
digital kind of offers a big safety net,
really that if something goes wrong,
you know,
a tree falls over or whatever in the middle of a three day shot.
Right.
You don't have to start again,
you can paste it back up again in post.
Well,
there's this
amazing,
um,
coliseums scene and the arena where they're playing a football in there and I
really want to talk about it.
It's kind of mind blowing to me.
I'm like that all that could be stop motion or there has to be some digital
enhancements like the crowds and stuff.
But can you talk about kind of the breakdown of how you did the world of saying,
okay,
this is going to be puppet and this is going to be,
yeah.
Well all the old principal character animation throughout the movie is,
is all stopped frame,
you know,
with clay faces.
But sometimes the football picture for example,
it's like 30 feet long and you just couldn't reach characters at the other.
Oh yeah.
It was such a long walk around the set to me.
We went,
we went to digital at the back.
Anything in the background or massive crowd scenes when digital.
Yeah.
And the whole stadium is computer generated.
So it's just 35,000 seat stadium.
We can't make that many puppets.
Right.
So,
um,
we used a lot of VR for previous,
so will and I had a system where we could actually go into the stadium at the
puppet scale and fine and we calibrate the Vr to whichever lens set we were
using.
We could compose a shot and match it up to the stop motion frame on the set or
vice versa,
find a frame on the stop motion set and just reference it because obviously if
we're shooting on a blue screen or green screen,
we have no idea what the rest of the composition looks like.
So having,
using that technology was really,
really useful for us so we could sort of collide the old and the new,
um,
and make sure that it was going to be working in harmony.
And that was,
that was a really valuable tool to us.
But so that whole stadium is CG.
Um,
yeah it expands the world of stop motion cause obviously the puppets are a
certain size and the sets have to be built around them.
And although we did as much as we could in camera and using false perspective
and old traditional techniques,
there is that,
um,
that epic feel that you get from the stadium pitch made of grass and all of the
fence around the edge.
We had a physical,
uh,
field football field.
It's just everything beyond that,
everything beyond that was so interesting.
Especially for you guys as like animation directors when you're working with
these characters and stuff.
Is there anything that maybe surprise you about that was very difficult?
This go around from previous films in terms of it just difficult working with
the characters or the hair or the puppets?
All of those,
because you can correct me if I'm wrong,
but I think nick was really keen to go to quite a tactile,
very clay,
you know,
he wants to see the fingerprints and there's lots of uh,
and hair in this film,
which didn't exist on Wallace and gromit.
It was sculpted.
So the first challenge was finding materials that would let us really keep those
nice textures and the animators that she physically moving.
We see the for oiling around,
but that's all part of Caveman.
Yeah.
It's like we all realize how you could do wonderful ham and fair in CG and even
even many stock fame animators would shy away from the firm and looked in horror
when we presented the puffers.
But that's,
yeah,
like,
like say that so,
so it's a lovely quality that reminds you of the old King Kong and you know when
you get a little flick of the hair or it'll boil in the,
in the fair.
And that's all part of it.
It's always interesting is when there's something that seems so simple to an
audience,
but it's actually very,
very difficult.
Was there anything like that in the film?
They taste a simple shop.
It's actually deceptively difficult to do.
The big set pieces,
you know,
they're big set pieces and New York have a big run up to them.
You'll do a lot of testing and preparation.
It's actually the closeups,
the
when the shots have to act and they have to communicate a thought or a feeling
in the animators are actors and they have to make the audience understand what
that character is at that moment.
And those are the ones that are the hardest.
They really are.
You know,
the big set pieces are big and flashy.
They're complicated and difficult,
but actually there's a lot of distraction.
You can get away with a surprising amount of shots.
It's the intimate moments which are the hardest to do.
And then can you talk about a little bit about finding this talent to be able to
do this?
Cause it's a very limited number of people in this world can do this type of
animation.
Yes,
definitely.
I mean we had a wonderful team of 35 or 40 animators,
uh,
all very hem chosen,
um,
mainly guy.
You guys wasn't it?
And they were,
there were those,
uh,
doing what Merlin saying,
you're conveying a thinking character that's actually,
it's not just moving puppets and it's actually making them feel like they're
alive and breathing.
Um,
and there are probably a handful who are really excellent and,
uh,
and then,
another level who were pretty good,
you know,
and so we went on,
but obviously there were many shots that need really great acting.
And,
um,
so it was always a dilemma as to who to put on which,
which shot.
Right.
Which were the most important,
which took priority.
And were there any like tricks or kind of cheats that you were able to do
certain characters in terms of we can't get the hair to flow correctly,
right?
With the character or the capes?
Was it like always going to CG or they're like fun little tricks that you guys
can share in terms of specifically working with stop motion?
Uh,
the model team spent a long time actually before the shoot started and we always
do tests with the first version of each character.
Um,
but it was probably them using all the knowledge that they've built up from all
the previous films each time taking something to the next film.
Um,
they're using pretty much everything on each character is made to be movable.
So Doug's hair,
for example,
has individual wired strands so that each hair can be moved in my new details,
guests,
the hair and the phone was tricky.
There was one captain,
the captain of the bronze team is a very vain fellow.
He's always combing his hair and there's a couple of shots where he kind of
doesn't kind of,
uh,
like a shampoo commercial kind of
to get that,
to animate it.
Normally his hair's kind of all neat and tidy,
but you get that flood,
well how are we going to do this?
And actually the best way to do it is to get here and put wax in it and that
just animate it and don't try and be clever.
I just use the real thing and,
and the animators were kind of
not sure,
but that she wants to,
I had to go to it and sort of worked out the limitations of where it could go
and what they can do with it.
Then actually it sort of exceeded expectations.
And that's one of the great things where you just need to have a go at it.
Quite often it'll work rather than trying to overthink the problem.
What was something that you took from your previous owners?
We did touch on that,
the degree periods forms as you're able to use on this,
like,
oh,
why you use this trick or I'll use this idea or,
well,
the main thing is,
is the,
there's the sculpting nature.
Um,
we've,
we've done a couple of,
we did a film with a rapid prototype,
kind of three d printed faces for dialogue.
And then this,
we really went back to using full clay.
We've got a mouth set here and so the,
the basic speech is done with clay.
So it's
in one sentence.
We were pushing the level of performance animation,
but we would,
we were,
I don't want to call it a step back,
but we were going back to a trusted technique which we were all very comfortable
with,
which was using pure modeling clay for the,
all of the expressions,
expressions and expressive performances from the characters.
Wow.
That's crazy.
Um,
yeah.
Also I suppose the technique or rather the style is,
is,
uh,
specific to Nick's work.
So we've had different directors on different films and pirates was Lord and um,
and we've had Richard Star Zach on Sean,
and each of them have a slightly different thing that they look for in the
performance and the movement.
So we had to work with the,
all the animators that had worked with nick before inherently learning his
actual sort of slightly bolder,
more graphic style,
and then training up some new animators in,
in that way of specific bold the entity.
Is that difficult for you guys in terms of keeping characters on model as you go
through a different form?
It's probably the biggest part of our job actually.
Yeah.
And that's partly the reason for these mouth,
isn't it?
For these clay mask,
I don't know if you can see them at all.
It's a technique we started using.
Thirdly,
they use something similar on nightmare before Christmas with replacement heads.
And we under a close shave back in 97 we use,
we did some mailings,
just been through the,
the idea.
But we,
yeah,
we unplug to say the animator sculpting the whole mouth again.
Um,
we have these ready made males Jara pluggable,
but they're all still made of clay as you were saying that so that you can still
squeeze them.
And so it doesn't film to mechanical is still half the organic field,
but that keeps to style consistent
all hand sculpted by the assistant animators.
So each,
each Doug puppet,
we'll have a set of mounts and each new food.
Yeah,
we made thousand.
What we the royal we right.
Thousands of mouth,
uh,
over the course of the movie.
Yeah.
And another thing,
the way here we adopt to technology,
uh,
all the way through different films and probably more so on this than ever.
Um,
but there's,
there's one way in which the digital side,
it just helps us go faster really with the stop frame is that in the old days
there's a lot of running around in this film and jumping in,
uh,
in the old days we would have today for character left the ground,
we would have to get w fishing line or thin wire and it will take the animator
age is to position and then find out the why.
It's catching the light,
you know,
and,
and so with this,
we just have like a dirty great big rig behind the character ans,
and the animated doesn't have to be worry about it being seen because we just
painting around after afterwards.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's nuts.
So that speeds up the whole person for sure.
Um,
questions.
When you are working with CG animation,
do you
like,
it looks too polished?
Like how do you,
how difficult is it to take like the perfect in between the interpretation of
the computer and then have take it back a bit to look more like the creative
vision of,
of stop motion?
It's very difficult.
Well that we've worked very hard on,
we did all our CG animation in house,
so our head of animation,
Lloyd Price,
he supervised the CG and we automate most of our movies on double frames,
taking two frames at a time.
So 12 frames a second and a computer animation prefers single friends or you
know,
blurring,
you know,
it's a much slicker.
Um,
and just,
just making sure that the CG felt appropriate and embedded says that it wasn't
sort of a,
like they were invaders from another planet in your movie.
It had to feel like it was the same team playing together and,
and that that was just a period of testing.
And once we understood what it was,
then it's a very easy thing to then apply then to the rest of the performance of
the digital levels
we have,
we have to work in quite an economic way as well with all evil,
with the foreground,
with,
sorry,
with the background,
any,
any of the figures that were,
cause we couldn't really afford the rendering time and the uh,
the quality that most CG films would have.
So we had to keep an ECG had to be out of focus or in the distance.
It's like I was not going to,
I love that stuff.
That's great.
Um,
can you talk a little bit about to disappear Lord and David's Brockton
approximate in terms of what their involvement is with the film and,
and um,
yeah.
Are they giving any story ideas or guidance?
Yeah.
Well,
they are a very much a part of the whole process from the very beginning.
You know,
when we start pitching ideas and ideas that get green lit and,
and uh,
uh,
and then they're very handy,
you know,
coming in on the edit and giving advice and uh,
uh,
right to the end,
right through and on script as well.
Yeah,
lots of script,
10 days.
Yeah.
I see.
You're very involved with obvious as well from some of the clubs we saw was
your,
uh,
shooting reference footage and you're,
you're in there and you're kind of giving the idea what you,
why are you also working with,
obviously you guys pop in there as well as sometimes.
Um,
do you work obviously with individual animators as well and be like,
Hey,
give me your take on it as well,
or is it,
um,
what's the,
what's the balance do you find there?
Because I was directing this one alone because most feature films tend to be two
handers and we've got that,
we picked that up from,
from when we,
with dreamworks and the Disney model.
Uh,
because there's such a vast amount of work to do and to oversee every detail
and,
and uh,
so you have to have a,
in this way you have to organize and you know,
had a very strong team in Welland,
Merlin at the top.
Uh,
so we would talk endlessly about the scene and the essence of what the spirit of
every shot is about and what every shot has to accomplish.
Uh,
and we would get down on the floor in front of a video camera and acts swale and
these guys with more relay this to the animators and look after teams of
animators occasionally I would as well.
Yeah.
That was mainly your job wasn't,
yeah,
but you were,
um,
through,
through the whole process and all the effort,
a lot of the effort goes into the preps.
So all the art department meetings,
the design of the props and the puppets,
everything at that point is overseen.
And then up to the point where the animator starts the shop,
that's where we sort of fill in that gap gadget.
And the animators do bring all of them,
bring things to each shop.
They're all individuals and they're all actors and they all got ideas.
So I'm definitely,
they dug,
the character evolves as more animators join and bring their own sort of flavor
to them.
Right?
So the storyboard a reference,
like here's the guidance for you.
We need to get from point a to point B,
but within those,
you know,
yeah,
yeah.
Make sure that whatever was coming to the shop was going to make the shot better
and,
and still be following the vision for the movie.
And the major difference with stop motion is that you only get the one go really
because you start the beginning,
you finished the anticline,
go back and adjust in the middle.
Right?
So the pressure is on everyone to get to get it.
Right.
And so,
um,
we really welcome ideas from everyone and every,
every department of the movie.
But there comes a point where you have to just go,
okay,
well let's look at this,
this,
this and this and that.
It's good.
And make it,
make the decisions to,
to go ahead and,
um,
yeah.
And,
and,
and because we can have that level of a little bit of flexibility and
spontaneity,
it means that it allows,
you know,
if nick needs to adjust something from a story point of view or the art
department need to change something,
then we can accommodate that.
But once it's in,
then that's,
so that's a continuity reference that has to be fallen for the rest of the film.
So you also have to kind of keep all of those in your head.
Right.
I watched a budget,
special features from you guys on DVD when I was a kid and I remember the,
uh,
the biggest thing that I've heard from any,
um,
but are you doing stop motion animation?
Is that it's a dying art.
And,
um,
I wanted to ask you specifically to comment on the industry.
I know to,
to mind it's you guys,
and I think Laika,
I don't know if they're still around,
um,
but,
uh,
you know,
where do you guys see the future of the industry?
You know,
how connected are you guys?
And,
um,
and,
uh,
is it going to continue or they're going to be new people coming on to
hopefully,
uh,
keep it,
keep it alive going forward.
It's not the up.
Yeah.
I remember,
uh,
you know,
20 or 30 years ago with the rise of CG,
uh,
how we used to look at each other and thinking how,
how long do we have left?
And,
uh,
and,
and we're still here,
but it's amazing how much it's hasn't,
you know,
how it is still flowering as an industry.
Um,
you know,
that there was like a,
uh,
you know,
films that Tim Burton is coming up with and um,
whereas Anderson was Anderson's just about to release another stop frame film
last year.
It's actually really hard to get animators.
It was more and stop motion.
How many was it?
It was four,
four [inaudible],
which has never happened ever.
It was quite amazing.
We normally sorts of,
from the previous films,
it seems like Tim Burton and up and do them exactly the same time.
And then there's a gap of several years.
But actually it's sort of picked up a bit of pace.
So it's quite a good time.
Some of our team or come over and work at liker and,
and um,
then where's movie and then come to us.
And so it's,
it's a really nice,
it's a small world.
It's a relatively small corner of the animation world cruise.
Many crew members do kind of work on production.
So that's really healthy.
Yeah,
that's crazy that there's four in production.
That's nuts.
I guess it's,
it can survive as long as we're all telling good stories and compelling stories
with compelling characters
to follow on that there is a huge part of the process that's simply writing.
Right.
And I guess I'm curious how attached you are to the difficulty of going from the
rating to the final product.
So if it were possible to go from your lab team and you know,
magically produce a visual results that had all of the charm that you could ever
want,
would you be sad?
I've had all of that.
Yeah.
Like if the lab,
you could train up an AI model to sort of like look at all the films you've ever
done and then say,
oh,
I get it.
And apply that to
pass the test.
If you,
if you looked at it and said,
oh my God,
that's beautiful.
I wouldn't change a thing.
Wouldn't you be sad?
Are
you were framing,
if you guys,
what are we working on?
The writing is the story and how much of it is the process of the process
basically vanished.
Could you be sad?
No,
no.
I mean the writing is such a,
before any animations doesn't think that writing is just so key to coming up
with the idea and the structuring of the idea and the art chemo cause that's
where the,
the real,
uh,
you know,
bedrock is created for everything.
Um,
you know,
the,
the arc of the story,
each character with their own arc.
And I was in a room with Mark Burton and another writers came in at different
times.
Uh,
just look staring at cards on a wall.
You know,
so much of that goes on before anything's built anythings without that,
there's nothing to,
to make,
you know.
Um,
so,
uh,
yeah,
it's a very key and then,
then we find that even the writing on the page,
then we start storyboarding and that becomes a very different animal because it,
how to interpret what's on it's,
you know,
it's easy to say they saw the hat on the page and then you have to execute each
bit as a scene.
And uh,
it's all about the timing of each scene and what the scene's about.
And then suddenly you find actually one scene knocks out in another scene and
contradict something else.
And then we start to plan the anime,
you know,
set up what we think was a really strong sort of blueprint in storyboard a
suddenly become slightly another reality when you're setting up the camera on
the floor and things change again a little.
So it's a very fluid,
you know,
I think all of us started from a point where we just enjoyed the making or doing
when we were sort of on a very innocent level before it gets kind of big and
serious.
Gotcha.
You just kind of
making we had,
I think that's,
I think I'm probably wouldn't miss filmmaking.
Yeah.
And last person,
thank you for being here and uh,
thank you for bringing such joy into the world.
Oh,
thank you.
Um,
I guess related to that previous question,
are there happy accidents that occur that would only happen and be part of the
process if it,
because you were working with a physical medium,
you should be cleaned out.
Yeah.
The Ra.
Well,
yeah,
because it's um,
because it's stopped frame or stop motion animation.
No two shots will ever be the same and each animator we'll do something
different to everyone else.
So almost every shop contains a unique sort of piece of performance,
I suppose.
And sometimes things go wrong in the shot and sometimes the characters can't do,
they were meant to do
and we have to adapt and change it,
which is just unique to this medium,
I think.
Um,
but also that expression that comes from grommets,
brows and,
and these characters browse,
it's very,
very unique to this style.
They can go one or two ways.
Either it's unexpected and it's a disaster or as unexpected,
and you think,
oh my goodness,
that's amazing.
That never would have happened if we sort of asked for it.
Um,
and so you can,
you kind of have to roll with the punches like that.
Yeah.
I'm trying to think of an example,
but there have been happy times as well when the story,
cause we,
you know,
we make the whole film and storyboards for,
than,
and see how the whole shape of it's working and the,
but then when you get the unlimited sex,
you're not saying you can be really surprised at things,
take on a different meaning.
And sometimes it allows you to,
hell,
maybe we don't need this shot next to it.
It's just funny on its own or so things happen like that all the time.
Great.
Thanks so much,
guys,
for being here.
Uh,
[inaudible].